look at Nate here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel today we're going magnet
fishing but first you need to stop
teasing the bird alright guys it's a
cold but beautiful day here and we're at
a really popular boat ramp and we're
gonna go magnet fishing and we're not
going to just use any old magnet
I've got a super freaky powerful
dangerous magnet that I'm gonna use and
it's it's pretty crazy I'm gonna show it
to you guys here we're gonna start
fishing off of these piers now if you
follow my channels on my other channel
the catfish and carp YouTube channel I
did a magnet fishing video at this spot
a couple years ago but a lot of crab
gets dropped here so we're gonna give it
another go this is the magnet I'm going
to be using it's a 500 pound iot magnet
I may not be pronouncing that right but
on amazon.com this thing is crazy
powerful I have another one that's a 250
pound magnet and I got those suckers too
close together once and they snap
together and pinched a bit of my skin in
between the two took 30 minutes to get
them apart
I had to beat on with hammers and set up
a block and tackle I mean they're
legitimately a 500 pound magnet if this
thing gets stuck on something large and
metal and gets a good flat surface to
surface contact yeah it's I might not
get my magnet back so this is a very
powerful magnet but if there's anything
metal down here we're gonna find it and
you see that and go and bounce it up and
down okay and kind of walk along oh look
at this
something stuck to it what is this okay
there's there's a washer and this this
is like I do that having a bungee cord
hook okay
alright let's let's go you want to put
the treasure in the bucket okay
oh wow I can't get it off see that's
what I mean about this thing being
dangerously powerful I mean when stuff
gets stuck to it it's it's really hard
to get it off I'm gonna worry I just
felt something clicked to it okay pull
it up he'll you got a bottle cap yeah
that bottle cap here let's go put it in
the foot in there with the other stuff
oh there's something there's something
big down there oh there's something big
down there it is struggling it's it's
down there oh and popped off again I can
hear it I get here it goes click and
then it I feel like there's a fishing
lure down there cuz I can hear you go
Tina and stick to it I can pull it up
and almost get it to the surface and
then get resistant and it gets pulled
off another bottle you're pulling up for
me see if there's anything on there oh
just more dirt look at this look at
these we got magnetic rocks here - yeah
there's magnetic rocks a little keychain
ring yeah what are these things sir
they're metal but I'm there's tons of
them these little oval shaped pieces of
metal about six or seven that we found
leave a comment if you think you know
what those are oh there's a little
swivel
yeah a little bit of iron or coconut
juice I just found so dice and it's
hustle I think it's a camping chair what
camping chair for sale gently used looks
like somebody lost a transom saver yeah
that's that's goes on the back of the
trailer save the save the outboard motor
from you break it
[Music]
we're gonna try one more spot and then
let Nathan here have a potty break and a
little food in them you're tired buddy
I just ran some savers leaking crap all
over so I'm gonna put that there
well guys here's another spot you may
recognize for my fishing videos this is
the tidal basin in Washington DC and
that right there is the Jefferson
Memorial the Washington Monument and
we've got the Martin Luther King
memorial down there and the Roosevelt
Memorial a lot of people walk and fish
along this tidal basin and hoping we
find some things that have been lost
all right one of my favorite fishing
spots here and see if we can find
anything
I caught an American eel what Maddie did
fishing he was living inside that pipe
she put him back in the water yeah let's
go hey you go days off well that's an
absolute first I've never caught an eel
magnet fishing that's unusual oh man I
just lost my magnetic came unscrewed and
uh there we go well I think that's it
for our magnet fishing trip today
well that'll be a lesson for me next
time I'm going to superglue the threads
on my magnets oh that can't happen let's
see what we got in our treasure bucket
shall we a whole bunch of bottle caps
some punji cords part of a fishing reel
that was my favorite now I thought that
was cool look how many bottle caps we
got we must have 20 bottle cops down
there Amy did you have fun did you have
fun magnet fishing no I had a good time
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video do
if you want to see our other magnet
fishing video where we're a little bit
more successful check out the link in
the description if you guys want to see
more great videos from the outdoor Boise
youtube channel don't forget to click
subscribe that's right